return of politics now president-elect
joe biden is projected to win the state
of nevada
but the trump team is still fighting
back republicans claim voter fraud here
in clark county
we have hector mehim live outside
election headquarters up in north las
vegas with the details good morning
hector
hey there alex good morning and this is
just one of multiple lawsuits the trump
campaign has filed against clark county
they are making repeated claims of voter
fraud in last week's election
however the trump team has yet to
present evidence that voter fraud
happened
at a scale large enough to swing the
election
and the campaign announced heading back
to court today to challenge election
results
trump's team claims they have proof of
thousands of examples of what they are
calling voter irregularities
this includes the allegation that at
least two dead people
in clark county cast votes in a
statement clark county said
those claims are being investigated and
at the center of this battle as we've
been telling you
is the use of an automated signature
verification machine
the clark county registrar went with
a machine called the agilis machine
and at least 200 000
votes were counted through the signature
verification process
of this machine only i repeat for the
media
no human beings looked at those
signature matches to confirm
they were in fact matches
according to registrar of voters joe
gloria when the machine does not
find a signature match a worker checks
by hand
in a process that has multiple steps the
counting continues here at election
headquarters this morning with a small
batch of a little over 16
thousand mail ballots left to be
processed yesterday
we're expecting new vote totals this
morning there are also
60 thousand other ballots those are
provisional ballots left to sort through
and the county has maintained that they
are not aware of any improper ballots
being counted
some lawsuits have already been
dismissed we'll keep you posted what
happens
with this one reporting live outside
election headquarters in north las vegas
hector mejia
8 news now hector thank you very much 5